it's a time it's like well why are you
doing this entire time then for one you
take forever and then when you start it
started in a new one giving you time to
prepare
that's not prep that's not giving
attention yeah you're right it's me just
being really slow and then hitting the
record button I understand yeah you
could say I'm a horrible boss around
here
huh funny way we're gonna introduce this
trailer now what it was joking I know
I'm not your boss Jesus Horrible Bosses
- you're right man it's [ __ ] hot as
hell in here right now
[ __ ] I was like man I'm sweating my
balls off in here I am I was complaining
to him how hot it was like five minutes
ago and like he looked at me with this
look on his face like we drink any water
today I actually said have you drunk in
any water the correct pronunciation she
just saw the trailer again for Horrible
Bosses when I wanted her to watch it
first one just yeah so she can get like
you know for me a little bit of idea
what it's about
I remember that movie yeah and I loved
it I thought was hilarious it was like
one of those nice comedy surprises I
heard they were doing a sequel and I was
like can you really do a seagull this it
seems kind of just be gimmicky like are
they just gonna want to kill their
bosses all over again but the cast is so
good though like the three of those guys
you've got Jason Bateman Jason Sudeikis
Charley hey des
I know yeah I met Charlie day once on
its Always Sunny in Philadelphia set
yeah I met him when I I didn't have to
so I had a line and it's always son
I'm gonna lie it sounds very dangerous
outside I want to go out there yeah
that's the smart mighty hug Charlie day
yeah I didn't have some facilities sunny
in philadelphia drunk kid number two I
didn't know that yeah
first season in Netflix find that
episode let me know awesome yeah I met
Charlie dead you cracked up a tie one
line and at the time I was like this
show is gonna be stupid I don't believe
in this at all cuz it was just the first
season that hadn't heard anything yet
and then I finally saw the show like
four years later it's like this is a
hilarious show now I'm like addicted to
it but yeah this I wanna watch this
trailer too much talking we're doing one
two three
oh hello Nick guy who saved my life I'm
screwed my wife died was a bull and
hopefully okay sorry so what do you want
to tell her I said hi pls yo Crimmins
you tried to kill your bosses now that
you want to perpetrate a kidnapping
see you can't have this both ways Jonna
craziest criminals I've ever met you
wanna pull this [ __ ] off you gotta act
like word turned out all right
no that was embarrassing
we're trying to do a super cool slow-mo
walk guy come on man no no it's over
let's go go moronic idea I boys you ever
done it in a dentist's chair why don't
you quit get the chair ready I'm just
gonna visit the men's room real quick
you're welcome to do that on me oh well
it's her and
all right good it means a good teacher
man cuz it's like you're sound exactly
telling you what's going on but still
it's like it looks like it's gonna be
really fun again that's all that really
counts at the end of the day what do you
think about her she's awesome I love
that she's playing this character and
this like she's got a very strong
character
I love how committed she is to the crude
humor like she is really committed to to
it she doesn't hold back at all you know
like someone with her kind of like for
what she normally portrays it was really
kind of shocking to me when I saw it the
first time yeah it was like whoa she's
really like going all out there as being
like kinky nasty [ __ ] - so what okay
she's [ __ ] ridiculously hot dude I
mean the three guys just look like
they're having a good time together -
but it doesn't feel like it's forced or
something like that yeah you know so
yeah good chemistry yes they the
chemistry is so natural I wanted
probably really good buddies yeah
exactly
let's hope so reading an article today
about how Ryan Gosling and Rachel
McAdams originally did not get along
really son of the notebook and they once
got into a very big yelling match
awesome there was there was like a lot
of tension it's good yeah
tension is good for an actor and then
and then you know they are dating for a
few years who woulda thunk it hell yeah
hell yeah they're all special yeah it's
probably a lot of emotional abuse
between the two but maybe I'm reading
into this too much thank you guys for
letting us saw the trailers out if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe right here and you can also
subscribe to Veronica's Channel she does
a lot of music and such and she talks to
you and what have you how do I describe
your channel it's basically a vlog a
cover god playlist and couple of my
reels acting of my work that I've done
in the past so cool stuff check it out
cheeky just cheeky did it hey what um
there's something we have to do what do
we have to do Ryan
we gotta shut some [ __ ] out
spade prep if you have a big dick Ryan
right give me a shout-out or else I will
send my secret assassins to cut your
dick off and I will feed it to my dogs
PS love your videos that was fun
it gives me bread haha sky okay
Xavier Salazar he said hey sorry for
asking but I told the story about how I
got a blow job when I was high way oh my
god it was Veronica and yes it was
Veronica it was her and I'm here to
expose it no it was nothing we've never
dated before
so that's sure I do say my ex-girlfriend
ah Xavier Salazar I have achieved the
art of getting to your shout out my
friend I love you for who you are not
who you are on the outside on the
outside
great that's why I you're right you're
stretching me I'm trying to be perfect
you procede did you get to my shot I so
yeah I love you damn it Veronica you
made me lose my train of thought
Darren Ellis he said uh shout out maybe
huh well maybe I'll give you chef maybe
I'm one I'll give you thinking about
thinking about does it benefit me to
give you a shout out
cuz I am of hierarchy in this thing am I
going to get better with my words me do
articulate yeah mm-hmm you're so hot
they never told you that like just like
that you have I do remember some I was
camping once and I was in a bikini and a
guy a random stranger was just as I was
passing but I did say that straight but
but I'm just looking at you my boyfriend
that was really angry up at the time
nice did you cheat on your boyfriend
with that guy cuz that's what I would
have done if I was in your situation if
I had a vagina [ __ ] the things I would
do with guys it's all about the
sensation it's not gay what I'm thinking
yeah how we got yeah it's just supposed
to be a shout out to dare and how its
Darren Ellis my friend you are an
American Hero you you you ah you know
huh ah yes son of a [ __ ] oh you son of
a [ __ ] you was pretty good yeah
1920s henchman son of a [ __ ] you Hey a
boss